I don't think it's a big deal to say these rituals. It's
easy if you don't see the real
thing.
I don't say that I got Mr. Harue Lee. Among them, Irakata is already
a finger village to use as a rice village.
Hyun is the first rice paddy art in the industry. Hyun is a parent who these students are physically like
.
I think I should do this until the work I want to see.
[Music]
Rice paddy art is the color of energy.
Let's use 7 different types of rice to stop the good pattern of milk in the rice paddy
art. There is a sea. What kind of subject is next year?
Hit it and do it further. Ask the
art teacher to come down and make a detailed subject. When
it comes, the staff is a poor customer.
Yano Michiru It's probably better if you add seeds
here.  Get
a rice paddy art dog What color do you have in 9 minutes?
After that
, you will have to eat and eat.
Participants are 300 people on sale this year.
It's not easy to put it at first
, but before people come to other rice paddy art, you can
buy everything every
year.
The art people have stopped exterminating Taro's demons
since then.
[Music]
Hmm, the land where we first did it is not so much, but I
don't think it will happen.
It was just a countryside village, and now it's very much recognized as Sonya.
People in rural villages are proud of their rice paddy art everywhere they go.
[Music  ]